what people don't know what followers
don't know is as long as you borrow so
they would see Lamborghini lending me a
car for a week and oh my God he's like
23 and struggle ever get his kids
bawling that's not the case my name is
Mohammad see Danny my friends call me a
mood I am the top men's fashion
lifestyle blogger for the Middle East if
ever I meet someone that doesn't know
what a blogger is I described it someone
who has following that allowed them to
influence people brands work with me in
order to help shape their opinions and
shed a light on their products and their
services
I'm from Beirut Lebanon but I grew up in
Saudi Arabia my mom works with NGOs
around the Middle East and my dad was
heading research and development for an
oil company in Saudi Arabia for 30 years
I moved to Dubai six years ago to be a
buyer for level shoes which is the
biggest shoe store in the world and
introduced me to a lot of influential
people who have really shaped the
fashion industry I was with them for
three years until I decided to open a
store after I resign where I realized
that I wasn't ready so I was stuck I was
like what am I gonna do at that point I
was approached by a brand who doesn't
really fit with mr. Moody's Brad in
order to get them off my back I threw a
ridiculous number at them they're like
okay we'll do it I was shocked
it's then that I realized that there is
something here that hasn't been tapped
into in terms of immense bloggers to
this day there aren't many of us in
comparison to how many there are in the
female market
I do Barry's bootcamp five times a week
I then come back home shower have
breakfast and then day starts from
fittings to photoshoots two meetings
with brands and then every day I try and
make it a point to see my nieces and
nephew my family is my number one
supporters my mom loved it from the
get-go she introduces herself as mama
mood is really cute and I'm like mom
that's not like saying you're like
Beyonce's mother I'm fortunate enough to
have relationships with all major luxury
Brown I'm very guilty when it comes to
shoes I have way too many right now
they're so simple that they need we
found out we are about to go
a Nike event followed by Georgia and
then now we're going to trial with a
busy day let's go
I'm lucky enough to be at these events
see things ahead of the release air and
we get to do experiences like I think
today we're customizing Nike shoes
should be reading
[Music]
[Music]
um see just sign my donkey by 92 this is
a really big deal that's like getting
Kanye signing my proudest moments was
last year I was able to take my whole
family on vacation to the ball view and
this was on like a bloggers expense
where the hotel was given to us for free
flights were given to us for free just
because I would be talking my dad got so
upset with me on that trip because I
wasn't enjoying the moment I was really
trying to get the shot and like enjoy it
take this in here in the Maldives and
that was an eye-opener so now I'm
traveling and it is a sponsored hotel
I'll get the shots done in the first
half of the day and then I'll get to
enjoy the rest Metro what are you
changing now I'm painting my top and
there's another topic oh god we gotta go
sweetie you're a nun change back into
the previous outfit head to the new
butantã and then I bid you farewell
[Music]
you're somewhat categorized and in a box
not to say that they're limiting you but
they just have an image of what a male
persona should be when I first started a
lot of people were asking questions like
it is not like a lot of other guys this
is not what we're used to seeing you get
to really open up people's eyes and
change their opinions to what should be
accepted in terms of fashion I've always
wanted to be my own individual I wanted
to hate things done a lot of guys
wouldn't really wear and say look it
could work I'm not waiting for someone
else to tell me that it looks good to
think that it looks good I was bullied
as a kid I wasn't like the other boys I
wasn't into sports I would rather talk
about clothes nothing to do with the
Middle East it's worldwide people are so
eager to categorize
and when you don't fit into that box
that's just extra paperwork for them so
it pisses them off
that's why right now so all about live
the life you want to live and be happy
because at the end of the day that
relationship you have with yourself are
the most important relationship you'll
ever work on I was broken until three
years ago it was only recently that I
learned to go myself I was looking for
the things because I thought this would
fill that void and when the fame came I
somewhat got uncomfortable with it I
won't point because I feel like it's a
real invasion of privacy but when I
learned was all along I had the power to
fill that void my phone it was part of
my journey to become a blogger I don't
claim to know it all but I've learnt a
lot and a lot of what I've learned could
help others today and everything that
was on my to-do list tomorrow gotta come
back to so DXP laughter unum Xu some
looks
it's just ongoing it never stops people
think that blogging is just like you're
just having fun if you do it properly
it's actually a lot of work some days
you do get tired and some days you're
like do I want to keep doing this do I
want to keep putting my life in the
right
for judgment but you just need to think
about why you started I started doing
this because I want to make a change I
wanted people to see me doing what I'm
doing and see me doing my own thing and
say you know what if he did it but I can
do you think in a way you contributed to
changing views on Middle East about
men's fashion I've definitely
contributed something to changing
opinions for sure I think everyone has
you have no idea how many times I've
been stopped at the airport for random
security checking because my name is
much more or I'll like to have a
conversation with someone I'll be in the
State Bank oh my god your English is
perfect it just shocks me that some
people are not as educated with other
parts in the world it's a two-sided
thing it's not a one-sided thing but I
do hope that I'm changing people's views
I want to leave this earth having said
that I was here like I want to leave it
better than
[Music]
do you know what's Hispanic Heritage
Month nobody you got four more Latino
content right here